.
Ich würde jetzt sagen,
wenn man die zehn dazurechnet,
sind wir bei 18 ...
... also wahrscheinlich
in der Gegend um 30,
also 30'000 Fr.
* Angespannte Musik *
Verschuldet mit Verlustscheinen
bin ich ...
... bin ich bei 87'000.
* Angespannte Musik *
Jetzt weiss ich es nicht ganz genau,
aber es waren einmal 55'000.
Und jetzt habe ich
schon 15 Monate abbezahlt.
* Angespannte Musik *
Wie viel es genau ist,
weiss ich nicht,
aber wenn man alles zusammenrechnet,
wären es rund 10'000 Fr.
* Angespannte Musik *
Wer jung in die Schulden gerät,
findet oft lange nicht mehr heraus.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Das Leben ist teuer in der Schweiz.
Wer nicht viel verdient,
muss sein Geld gut einteilen.
Vielen Jungen fällt das schwer.
Letzten Sommer
bin ich an einem Punkt angekommen,
an dem ich die Miete
nicht mehr zahlen konnte.
Dann habe ich gemerkt: "Oh, oh!"
Jetzt wird es eng, jetzt muss ich
wohl bald aus der Wohnung ausziehen.
Zur Kündigung
kam kurz darauf die Lohnpfändung -
es ist nicht ihre erste:
Kiri lebt mit Schulden -
schon seit sie volljährig ist.
Mit 18 kamen die ersten
Briefe vom Betreibungsamt.
Vorher übernahmen das meine Eltern,
oder halfen mir dabei.
Aber dann hiess es: "Du bist 18,
du bist jetzt volljährig."
"Du musst jetzt selbst schauen."
Ich denke,
ich habe nie wirklich kapiert,
wie wichtig es eigentlich ist,
dass man weiss,
wo man finanziell steht.
Ich habe mich
nicht wirklich darum gekümmert.
Heute lebt sie
auf dem Existenzminimum.
Sie hat sich ihrer Mutter anvertraut,
ein WG-Zimmer gesucht
und sich ein Ziel gesetzt.
Erst musste ich mir
einen Überblick verschaffen:
Wo habe ich offene Schulden?
Das haben wir
jetzt langsam abgearbeitet.
Jetzt schauen wir
mit dem Betreibungsamt,
wo Pfändungen und
wo Betreibungen anstehen.
Nachher muss ich
einen Plan erstellen,
bis wann wir alles
wie bezahlen können.
Nachher beginnt das Abbezahlen.
Seit Kurzem hat sie
Ordnung in ihrem Postfach.
Die Situation am Briefkasten ist
für viele Überschuldete ein Problem.
Früher habe ich mich so verhalten,
dass ich die Briefe
aus dem Briefkasten nahm
und sie einfach
in den Milchkasten legte,
der sich langsam füllte,
bis schliesslich
beide Fächer überfüllt waren.
Dann forderte mich der Postbote
mit einer Notiz auf,
den Briefkasten zu leeren, weil er
keine Post mehr einwerfen könne.
Wie hast du es jetzt geregelt?
Jetzt leere ich
den Briefkasten regelmässig.
Wichtig war auch, dass meine Post
nicht mehr hierher geliefert wird,
sondern zu meiner Mutter.
Sie schaut,
ob etwas Wichtiges darunter ist,
und schreibt mir oder ruft mich an.
Wenn es Rechnungen sind,
kümmert sie sich darum.
Klar ist es mein Ziel, dass sich das
irgendwann wieder ändert,
dass ich meine Post,
meine Rechnungen erhalte.
Aber im Moment
ist das für mich der beste Weg,
weil ich sonst
komplett überfordert wäre.
Kiri steht ganz am Anfang
ihrer Schuldensanierung
und versucht es
noch ohne professionelle Hilfe.
Erika Müller
ist schon einiges weiter.
Auch sie ist mit der Volljährigkeit
in die Schulden gerutscht.
Als vor eineinhalb Jahren
gar nichts mehr ging,
hat sie bei der Schuldenberatung
Hilfe gesucht
und hat seither
keine Lohnpfändungen mehr.
Ich habe einen Schaden
an einem Auto verursacht.
Weil ich die Versicherung
zu spät bezahlt habe,
hat sich das überschnitten, sprich:
Ich blieb
auf den gesamten Kosten sitzen.
Aber nicht nur das.
Ich habe die Steuern nicht bezahlt,
die Krankenkassenprämien
nicht bezahlt,
hatte einen zu hohen Lebensstandard.
Nachher begann ich,
Kleinkredite aufzunehmen,
um die Steuern bezahlen zu können.
Das war ein Rad,
das sich abwärts zu drehen begann.
Die 35-jährige Lastwagenfahrerin
ist bei einer Stadt im Mittelland
angestellt
und hätte kein Problem gehabt
sich zu zeigen,
aber ihr Arbeitgeber
wollte das nicht.
Die Idee dieser Sanierung ist,
dass Sie
nach drei Jahren schuldenfrei sind,
dass die laufenden Steuern
bezahlt sind,
und Sie überall à jour sind.
Wenn wir Sie hier
aus der Schuldenberatung entlassen,
sollten Sie
wieder schuldenfrei starten können.
Jetzt liegen
noch 18 Monate vor Ihnen.
Wie blicken Sie auf diese Zeit?
Ich sehe schon ein kleines Lichtlein
am Ende des Tunnels,
es ist noch klein,
aber es kommt näher.
Irgendwann ist das Licht da,
das anzeigt:
Jetzt bin ich schuldenfrei.
Das wird ein neues Leben sein.
- Ja.
Erika Müller verdient 5'000 Fr.
und zahlt nach einem Sanierungsplan
monatlich 1'750 ab.
Sie ist eher die Ausnahme.
Nur 10 % der Klienten hier
können alle Schulden zurückzahlen.
Wollen wir schauen, wo Sie mit
dem Abbezahlen stehen?- Sehr gern.
Das ist Ihre Schuldenliste.
Und hier sehen Sie ...
... die Gesamtschulden,
diese 44'000 Fr.
Etwa 75 % des Schuldenbergs
liegt bei der Steuerverwaltung.
Da sind hohe Steuerschulden
aufgelaufen in diesen vier Jahren.
Dass man mit den Steuern
nicht nachkommt, passiert oft.
Und bei Lohnpfändungen
werden Steuern nicht ins
Existenzminimum eingerechnet.
Das macht es noch schlimmer.
Wer sich dann
anderswo zu verschulden beginnt,
wie z.B. im Fall von Frau Müller,
wenn irgendwann ein Unfall
mit einem Schaden hinzukommt,
wenn hohe Rechnungen anfallen,
die bezahlt werden müssen.
Und vielleicht ist
auch noch ein Kredit mit dabei
mit einer hohen Verpflichtung.
Weil sie die Steuerraten
nicht im Kopf hatte,
hatte sie das Budget schon
derart mit festen Raten ausgereizt,
dann wurde es schwierig.
Das war der Moment,
an dem es kippte,
an dem die Leute merken,
dass sie ihren Verpflichtungen nicht
mehr genügend nachkommen können.
In dieser Situation nahm Erika Müller
einen Kleinkredit von 10'000 Fr. auf.
Ich nahm den Kleinkredit auf, um
meine Schulden bezahlen zu können.
Das war natürlich wirklich
ein Schuss in den heissen Ofen.
Zwar habe ich
die Steuerschulden bezahlt,
aber logischerweise
kamen wieder neue Schulden hinzu,
und den Kredit
musste ich auch abbezahlen.
Im Rahmen der Schuldensanierung
stellte sich heraus,
dass mir dieser Kredit so gar nicht
hätte ausbezahlt werden dürfen.
Weil der Kredit gegen
das Konsumkreditgesetz verstiess,
konnte die Schuldenberatung
diese Forderung massiv reduzieren.
Aus Konsumkrediten sind total in der
Schweiz etwa 7,7 Mrd. Fr. ausstehend.
5 % der Haushalte
sind damit im Verzug.
Desinteresse oder Unwissen
ist im jugendlichen Alter häufig,
die Folgen aber sind fatal.
Yves de Mestral beschäftigt sich seit
Jahren mit überschuldeten Menschen
und weiss: Mit der Volljährigkeit
explodieren die Betreibungen
in der Schweiz um den Faktor 70.
Das Ausziehen von zu Hause
ist die grösste Schuldenfalle.
Krankenkassenprämien kosten bis 18
monatlich etwa 110 Fr. -
aber ab 18 kosten sie jedoch
bedeutend mehr: 300-350 Fr.
Wer direkt aus der Lehre kommt,
eine eigene Wohnung bezieht,
und neu eine Rechnung
über 350 Fr. erhält,
dann stellt das ein Problem dar.
Ein anderes ist die Steuerrechnung,
die ein bis anderthalb Monatslöhne
ausmacht.
Wenn noch anderes aussteht - Miet-
zins, Leasing etc. - wird es eng.
Das Budget ist eine gute Sache,
aber kein Allerweltsmittel.
Was kann das Budget nicht?
Themen wie diese
sind im Lehrplan nicht vorgesehen.
Darum bietet die Schuldenprävention
Zürich für Oberstufenklassen
Infoveranstaltungen an.
Etwa in jedem siebten Haushalt in der
Schweiz gibt es Zahlungsrückstände.
Es ist wichtig, seine Finanzen, sein
Geld, zu kennen und zu überblicken.
Nehmt das Budget hervor,
das ihr erstellt habt,
und vergleicht
eure Budgets miteinander.
Überlegt euch:
Was ist meine wichtigste Ausgabe?
Wo gebe ich mein Geld
am liebsten aus?
Was ist mir am wichtigsten?
Ausgang, genau!
Das ist deine Nr. 1, das ist okay.
Das darf es
natürlich auch sein, klar.
Weil heute alles
jederzeit verfügbar ist, hilft es,
wenn man schon früh
seinen finanziellen Rahmen kennt.
Die Möglichkeiten, die uns heute zur
Verfügung stehen, sind gestiegen,
um Sachen zu konsumieren.
Wenn ich morgens um 2 Uhr erwache,
kann ich im Internet einkaufen
und in 2 Min. 10'000 Fr. ausgeben.
Das war früher nicht möglich.
Früher konnte man sich sonntags
kaum verschulden, heute problemlos.
Diese Oberstufenschüler/-innen
beginnen bald mit einer Lehre
und haben mit ihren Eltern
unterschiedliche Budgetabmachungen
getroffen.
Am Ende meiner Lehre
erhalte ich das Geld zurück,
das ich meinen Eltern
monatlich gegeben habe.
Du hast 100 Fr. budgetiert?
Ja, das muss ich
meinen Eltern geben.- Genau.
Und am Ende meiner Lehre
bekomme ich das gesamte Geld zurück.
Aha, das ist quasi ein Depot.
- Ja.
Das ist originell,
das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Eltern sind wichtige Vorbilder,
auch in finanziellen Fragen.
Ich persönlich kann gut sparen.
Ich habe das so
von meinen Eltern gelernt.
Sie sagten mir immer: "Tu,
was du willst, aber spare trotzdem."
Wenn ich etwas sehe, das ich will,
denke ich nicht darüber nach, ob ich
Geld habe, sondern kaufe es einfach.
Das ist wie eine Sucht, deshalb
muss ich lernen, mit Geld umzugehen.
Normalerweise habe ich immer
etwas Geld auf die Seite gelegt,
aber irgendwie
ist es jetzt wieder weg.
Im Moment habe ich gerade
nicht so viel Geld.
Das Problem ist,
dass man sich nicht bewusst ist,
was man unternehmen kann,
wenn man in die Situation
der Überschuldung gerät.
Wenn man eine Rechnung oder Busse
nicht bezahlen kann,
gibt es einen Verlustschein,
der zwar 20 Jahre gültig ist,
aber im Moment
kümmert das niemanden.
Der Verlustschein bedeutet aber,
dass der Gläubiger,
dem man Geld schuldet,
die nächsten 20 Jahre eine
Betreibung in Gang setzen kann.
Sehr viele Menschen kommen bis
an ihr Lebensende nicht mehr daraus.
Das ist sehr dramatisch.
Donald Niebaum ist einer von ihnen.
Er ist auch sehr jung
in die Schulden geraten.
Jahre später ist sein Schuldenberg
auf 87'000 Fr. angewachsen.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Ich nehme auf jeden Fall
gerne eine Gurke.
Eine Gurke? Eine Schlangengurke?
- Ja, gerne.
Mittlerweile hat er eine Familie,
seine Partnerin
ist ebenfalls verschuldet.
Weder sie noch der gemeinsame Sohn
möchten sich in diesem Film äussern.
Und einen Blumenkohl.
- Gern.
Geht das auch ohne Tasche?
- Ja, das geht auch ohne Tasche.
Trotz Schulden kauft Donald
das Gemüse auf dem Markt.
Das ist mir mega viel wert.
Trotz Pfändungen und Betreibungen
kaufe ich am Wochenmarkt ein.
Seit Jahren leben er und seine
Partnerin mit einem Existenzminimum
von 3'800 Fr. -
obwohl er regelmässig arbeitet.
Wollen Sie den Kassenzettel?
- Ja, gerne.
In die Schulden geraten ist
der ausgebildete Maurer,
weil er beim Auszug
aus seiner ersten Wohnung
ein Auszugsprotokoll
unterschrieben hat,
auf dem grosse Schäden
aufgelistet waren,
die er gar nicht verursacht hatte.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Gleichfalls.
Am Anfang war es Desinteresse,
ich habe mich einfach
nicht darum gekümmert.
Irgendwann,
nach zwei bis drei Jahren,
als Betreibungen
und Lohnpfändungen einsetzten,
schlug es in Resignation über.
Ich wusste, dass es so war, also
würde es nicht mehr darauf ankommen.
Über die Jahre häuften sich so
auch Krankenkassen-
und Steuerschulden an.
Betreibungen reihten sich aneinander,
aus den Lohnpfändungen
kam er gar nicht mehr heraus.
Ich habe mich organisiert,
aber im Alltag
ist es eine ständige Belastung,
weil das Geld
wirklich an jeder Ecke fehlt.
Ich muss mir wirklich gut überlegen,
ob ich etwas kaufen kann.
Weil wir z.B. erst Kleider
für den Kleinen brauchen,
muss alles andere warten.
Nach 15 Jahren haben er und seine
Partnerin sich endlich aufgerafft,
etwas dagegen zu tun.
Mein Sohn hat mich
schliesslich auch dazu gebracht,
diesen Wandel zu vollziehen.
Nur habe ich gemerkt,
dass mein Versuch,
meine Schulden
mit viel arbeiten zu tilgen,
das funktioniert gar nicht.
Den Schritt zur Schuldenberatung
habe ich erst unternommen,
nachdem ich vom Obergericht
ein Schreiben erhalten hatte.
Eine weitere Jugendsünde: Donald
war ein leidenschaftlicher Sprayer
und wurde wegen Sachbeschädigung
mehrfach gebüsst.
Weil er eine Busse von 15'000 Fr.
nicht bezahlen kann,
muss er sie nun absitzen.
Jetzt hofft er, dass
die Schuldenberatung helfen kann.
Franziska Neuhaus ist heute 39.
Sie hat den Weg aus den Schulden
nach 20 langen Jahren
endlich fast geschafft.
Doch sie hat einiges in ihrem Leben
ändern müssen.
Das Hobby der gelernten Reisefachfrau
ist Nähen.
Früher hätte ich
Stoff auf Vorrat gekauft,
einfach weil ich ihn hübsch finde.
Dann wäre er einfach rumgelegen,
bis ich ihn zu einem günstigeren
Preis hätte verkaufen müssen,
weil ich ihn nie verwendet hätte.
Heute kaufe ich Stoff nur,
wenn ich ihn brauche
und eine direkte Verwendung
dafür habe.
Sie sucht Stoff, um ein Etui
für ihren E-Reader zu nähen.
Heute hat sie unterschiedliche Konten
mit unterschiedlichem Zugriff.
Ich habe eine Prepaid-Kreditkarte,
mit der ich das bezahle.
Die Prepaid-Kreditkarte
ist mein Taschengeldkonto,
auf das
jeden Monat 800 Fr. fliessen.
Das ist mein Taschengeld
für meine Freizeit.
Damit bezahle ich alles, was
keine monatlichen Fixkosten sind:
mein Vergnügen, meine Freizeit,
Sachen, die ich mir gönne.
Grüezi, ich möchte von diesem Stoff.
- Ja, okay.
Daneben habe ich ein Lohnkonto
für Allgemeinzahlungen,
Krankenkasse usw.
Das Sparkonto habe ich z.B.
nicht im Onlinebanking,
darauf habe ich
keinen Zugriff einfach so.
Das ist eine Barriere für mich.
Das macht 6.50 Fr.,
wenn Sie so gut sein wollen.
Mit der Karte, bitte.
- Mhm.
Ratenzahlungen kommen für sie
heute nicht mehr infrage.
Gar nicht, entweder kann ich
es mir leisten - oder nicht.
Wenn ich es mir nicht leisten kann,
warte ich drei Monate.
Hier Ihr Stoff, bitte.
- Vielen Dank, auf Wiedersehen.
Auch Franziskas Geschichte
ist typisch und hat früh begonnen.
SRF hat schon 2004
über sie berichtet.
Damals war sie 21
und mit 8'000 Fr. verschuldet.
Auch sie ist mit dem Auszug
von zu Hause in die Schulden geraten.
Angefangen hat es damit, dass ich
von zu Hause ausgezogen bin,
als ich noch in der Lehre war -
bei einem sehr kleinen Lohn.
Dieses Geld habe ich ausgegeben,
um Kollegen einzuladen,
habe sie zum Nachtessen
oder ins Kino eingeladen,
weil ich dachte, sie würden
nur dann mit mir ausgehen.
Oder ich ging shoppen und
kaufte irgendwelches Zeugs,
das ich ein halbes Jahr später
wieder wegschmiss,
weil ich es nie brauchte.
Ich ging oft nur shoppen,
weil es mir schlecht ging.
Vieles kaufte sie online
und wenn sie ihre Handyrechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen konnte,
wechselte sie einfach den Anbieter.
An die Steuerrechnung
dachte sie gar nicht
und anvertrauen
wollte sie sich auch niemandem.
In dieser Situation
habe ich mich extrem geschämt.
Ich getraute mich nicht,
mit jemandem darüber zu sprechen,
weder mit Kollegen
noch mit meiner Mutter,
ich ging auch
nicht zu einer Beratungsstelle.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
allein mit diesem Problem zu sein.
Deswegen ging es mir
auch sehr schlecht,
weil ich all diese Probleme
in mich hinein frass -
auf gut Deutsch.
Wenn an mich
adressierte Briefe kamen,
habe ich diese nicht geöffnet.
Ich legte sie in eine Schublade,
öffnete sie
erst zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt,
weil ich genau wusste,
dass letzte Mahnungen darunter sind
oder Betreibungsandrohungen.
Erst als sie ihre Miete
nicht mehr bezahlen konnte
und kurz vor einer Lohnpfändung
stand, ging sie zur Schuldenberatung
und liess sich zeigen,
wie man ein Budget macht.
Ich setzte mich hin, sortierte
alle Rechnungen und Mahnungen.
Ich merkte, dass es sich
z.T. um sehr hohe Beträge handelte,
die ich nicht in einem Mal
zurückzahlen kann.
Ich nahm mit den Gläubigern
Kontakt auf,
um mit ihnen einen Abzahlungsvertrag
abzuschliessen,
damit ich meine Schulden in mo-
natlichen Ratzen zurückzahlen kann.
Darauf haben alle positiv reagiert.
Ich konnte jetzt
ungefähr innerhalb eines Jahres
meine Schulden
in monatlichen Raten zurückzahlen.
Und ich konnte auch so zurückzahlen,
dass mir Geld fürs Leben
zur Verfügung stand.
Franziska schien ihre Situation
in den Griff zu bekommen
und hielt sich an ihr Budget.
In drei Monaten habe ich
alle meine Schulden abbezahlt.
Ich bin megafroh,
ist es endlich zu Ende.
Jetzt kann ich
endlich wieder Geld zur Seite legen.
Irgendwie bin ich
auch sehr stolz auf mich,
dass ich es alleine geschafft habe,
aus diesem Übel zu kommen.
Das war eine harte Zeit.
Ich musste ein paar Monate leiden.
Es war für mich auch eine gute
Erfahrung, bei der ich merkte,
dass es nicht viel braucht,
um glücklich zu sein,
dass ich mit viel weniger
glücklich sein kann -
zum heutigen Zeitpunkt.
Das war 2004.
18 Jahre später weiss sie,
dass sie viel zu optimistisch war.
Sie verdient 5'500 Fr. im Monat.
Davon gingen über Jahre 700-800 Fr.
für die Schuldentilgung weg.
Ich bin noch
nicht ganz schuldenfrei.
Ich vor vor etwa
sieben oder acht Jahren rückfällig -
rückfällig in Anführungszeichen.
Ich habe mir eine Kreditkarte
abonniert oder geholt in diesem Sinn
und habe eine Limite
von 10'000 Fr. erhalten -
einfach so.
Diese 10'000 Fr. habe ich in der
Folge sehr grosszügig ausgenützt,
die ich noch immer aktiv abbezahle -
noch bis Ende Jahr.
Dann ist - fertig.
Nie hätte sie gedacht,
dass es so viel schwieriger ist,
aus den Schulden herauszukommen
als reinzugeraten.
Das Schwierigste war wirklich,
alles irgendwann zahlen zu können,
denn es kam immer wieder
etwas Neues hinzu,
zu den laufenden Kosten
wie Steuern und Krankenkasse,
von denen man weiss,
dass es hohe Beträge sind.
Wenn ich zum Zahnarzt
oder Frauenarzt musste usw. -
das waren alles hohe Ausgabenposten,
die ich
nicht auf einmal zahlen konnte,
weil ich schon andere
Ratenzahlungen vereinbart hatte.
Dadurch stellten sich
immer wieder Verzögerungen ein.
Kannst du mir bitte mit der Erde
helfen kommen?- Ja, komme.
Heute lebt Franziska
mit ihrem Freund zusammen.
Für sie war von Anfang an klar, die
Finanzen müssen sauber geregelt sein.
Für unsere täglichen Ausgaben
wie Lebensmittel, Putzmittel usw.
besitzen wir ein Haushaltskonto, auf
das wir beide gleich viel einzahlen.
Wir kontrollieren auch nicht,
wer wie viel ausgibt.
Da sind wir völlig frei
und vertrauen einander.
Das läuft gut so.
Für grössere Anschaffungen
ist mittlerweile er zuständig.
Es hat sich so eingebürgert,
dass mir in dieser Wohnung
fast nichts mehr gehört.
Aber das ist für mich okay.
Am Anfang war es
schon etwas seltsam,
weil ich nicht damit gerechnet habe,
aber habe es schnell akzeptiert
und versucht, ihr dabei zu helfen.
Deshalb haben wir
gewisse Sachen nicht so getan,
wie ich es früher getan hätte,
um auf sie Rücksicht zu nehmen.
Ferien z.B. machen die beiden nur
tageweise und eher in der Schweiz.
Donald macht schon lange
keine Ferien mehr.
Die letzten 15 Jahre lebte er
praktisch immer mit Lohnpfändungen
und auf dem Existenzminimum.
Jetzt,
mit Hilfe der Schuldenberatung,
ist er erstmals
nach langer Zeit wieder draussen.
Bei der Schuldenberatung
konnte sie relativ schnell
klipp und klar sagen,
dass es gut aussehe.
Nach anderthalb Monaten
war die Lohnpfändung abgeschlossen.
Sprich: Ich musste
wieder ein Bankkonto eröffnen,
und erhielt eine Bankkarte,
damit man mir
den Lohn überweisen konnte.
Vor einem Monat
konnte ich zum ersten Mal
wieder selbst Geld abheben an einem
Bankomat - seit etwa sechs Jahren.
Ja, das war für mich
ein historischer Moment,
denn sonst holte ich mein Geld
immer auf dem Betreibungsamt ab.
Auf der Schuldenberatung
hat man Donald aufgetragen,
sich einen Überblick
über seine Ausgaben zu verschaffen.
Er hat ziemlich Respekt davor.
Ich weiss, wie heikel es ist,
was passieren kann,
wenn du dabei versagst.
Und ...
Mein Leben lang habe ich
nie die Verantwortung übernommen
für meine eigenen Finanzen.
Darum fühle ich mich
noch immer sehr schwach
und dieser Aufgabe noch
nicht unbedingt gewachsen, nein.
Ich hoffe, dass ich das schaffe,
glaube auch an mich selber,
dass ich es in den Griff kriege.
Aber ich hoffe, dass ich das erlerne
und meinem Leben beifügen kann,
damit es einfach läuft.
Aber die Schuldenspirale hört nicht
so schnell auf, sich zu drehen.
Schon wieder hat er vom Betreibungs-
amt eine Vorladung erhalten.
Mittlerweile ist er dort
ein alter Bekannter.
Grüezi, Frau Fasano.
- Grüezi, Herr Niebaum.
Also, es ist etwas Neues vom
Städtischen Steueramt gekommen,
ein neuer Zahlungsbefehl.
- Jawohl.
Ich stelle Ihnen diesen sofort zu.
So, das ist der neue Zahlungsbefehl.
- Jawohl, danke.
Klar, das wirkt jetzt
vielleicht wieder etwas krass,
dass ich wieder
2'000 Fr. neue Schulden habe,
aber in dieser Beziehung
bin ich auch etwas abgestumpft.
Jetzt ist es eben so.
Ich bin mir bewusst, dass es nicht
von heute auf morgen einfach wird,
schuldenfrei zu sein.
Sie haben ab heute zehn Tage Zeit
für einen Rechtsvorschlag
oder 20 Tage Zeit zum Zahlen.
- Okay.
Wenn Sie länger Zeit brauchen,
müssen Sie mit dem Kantonalen
Steueramt etwas abmachen.
Ja, das werde ich tun.
Ich werde dort sofort anrufen
und das mit ihnen besprechen.
Genau, besser mit ihnen als mit uns.
- Ja, genau.
So, und das von Kantonalen Steueramt
möchten Sie gerne zahlen?
Ja, genau.
Ich sage Ihnen gleich,
wie viel das ist.
Per heute
wären das insgesamt 493.82 Fr.
Okay.
- Haben Sie das dabei?
Ja, das habe ich dabei.
Eine neue Lohnpfändung
sollte er damit abwenden können,
aber seine Schuldenliste ist lang.
Einige Pfändungen konnte man decken,
andere nicht,
deshalb sind
Verlustscheine entstanden.
Momentan hat er 33 Verlustscheine
im Wert von insgesamt 88'000 Fr.
Ich muss es jetzt
einfach versuchen -
auch schlussendlich
der Familie und meinem Sohn zuliebe.
Ich will ihm wirklich
eine Zukunft bescheren können,
in der er unter Umständen nicht
meine Altlasten weiter tragen muss.
Dann gehen wir direkt zur Kasse.
- Ja, super.
Bitte kommen Sie mit.
Auf seine neue Bankkarte
hat er extra das nötige Geld geladen.
Bitte läuten Sie.
- Jawohl.
Und dann bitte einen Moment warten.
* Summton *
So.
Zahlen Sie mit EC
oder mit der Postkarte?
Mit der EC-Karte.
- Gut.
* Pieptöne *
* Angespannte Klänge,
langer Piepton *
* Angespannte Klänge *
Im Ernst?
Doch er hat zu knapp kalkuliert.
Zu wenig Geld drauf.
* Pieptöne *
Aber das Betreibungsamt
zeigt sich kulant
und rundet ausnahmsweise
um ein paar Gebührenfranken ab.
Das ist Ihre Quittung.
- Super, danke.
Das ist die Quittung, dass Sie
diesen Betrag bezahlt haben.
Jawohl.
Super, vielen Dank.
- Bitte sehr.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Auf Wiedersehen, Herr Niebaum.
- Ade, Frau Fasano.
Es ist nie ein schöner Moment,
wenn das Konto leer ist.
Ja ...
Aber ich bin zumal so weit froh,
will ich meinen,
dass ich
diese Pfändung zahlen konnte.
Damit kam es nicht zum Vollzug,
d.h., damit konnte ich
eine Lohnpfändung abwenden.
Yves de Mestral ist auch
Chef des Betreibungsamtes Zürich 3
und über Donalds Situation
informiert.
Hat er die Pfändung gezahlt?
- Ja.
Und die neuen 2'100 Fr.?
Habe ich ihm gegeben,
aber das konnte er nicht zahlen.
Aber er sagte,
er schaue das mit dem Steueramt an.
Wusste er davon?
- Nein, er wusste nichts davon.
Es wäre sinnvoll,
schon beim Start eines
Schuldensanierungsverfahrens
einen Schuldenruf zu machen,
damit man weiss,
wie viele Schulden
insgesamt offen sind.
Dann hat man eine gewisse Garantie,
dass nur diejenigen Schulden,
die angemeldet wurden,
zu zahlen sind,
und nachher
nichts Neues mehr hinzukommt.
Denn genau das ist es,
was den Erfolg eines Sanierungs-
verfahrens heute verunmöglicht
oder zumindest sehr erschwert.
So wie Donald
geht es vielen Menschen.
Allein 2020 wurden in der Schweiz
2,67 Mio. Betreibungen eingeleitet.
De Mestral
ist schon lange im Geschäft
und hat den Überblick
über die Zahlen.
Am häufigsten betrieben wird wegen
ausstehenden Krankenkassenprämien.
Was vom Betragsvolumen her
am meisten ausmacht,
sind Steuerforderungen,
weswegen Leute betrieben werden.
Rund 7,5 % der Schweizer Bevölkerung
leben in einem Haushalt
mit mind. einer
überfälligen Steuerrechnung.
5,5 % sind
mit Krankenkassenprämien im Verzug.
Das ist eine Besonderheit
in der Schweiz.
Im umliegenden Ausland
inkl. Lichtenstein
kennen alle Nachbarländer
den direkten Lohnabzug für Steuern,
für Krankenversicherungen
übrigens auch.
Man muss sich die Frage stellen,
ob es in der Schweiz
nicht an der Zeit wäre,
neue Wege zu beschreiten.
Die Steuern und Krankenkassenbeiträge
direkt vom Lohn abziehen?
Politisch schwierig in der Schweiz,
wo man Eigenverantwortung hochhält.
Doch das hätte Erika sehr geholfen.
Auch bei ihr
hat sich die Schuldenspirale
wegen Steuer- und Krankenkassen-
schulden immer schneller gedreht.
Diese Situation hat ihr
in den letzten zehn Jahren
psychisch massiv zugesetzt.
Mit 18 habe ich
das erste Mal gemerkt,
dass meine Familie nicht alle
Krankenkassenprämien bezahlt hatte,
dass ich da offene Beträge hatte.
Plötzlich hatte ich ...
... meine Finanzen
nicht mehr im Überblick.
Nachher kam es im Endeffekt
irgendwann zur Lohnpfändung -
mit 25 hatte ich meine erste.
Seither hatte ich einige.
Und weil ich Lohnpfändungen hatte,
konnte ich weder Steuern
noch Krankenkasse bezahlen.
Die unbezahlten Rechnungen
begannen, sich zu stapeln.
Ich sagte jeweils:
"Ich spiele Rechnungsbingo."
Ich öffnete das Couvert und riet:
"Kann ich es zahlen oder nicht?"
Als es nicht mehr ging ...
Ich versuchte, alles zu bezahlen,
wenn mein Lohn auf dem Konto war,
all die Daten bei den Steuern etc.
zu bezahlen.
Dann merkte ich schnell:
Wenn ich alles inkl. Miete bezahle,
bleiben mir bis Ende Monat
noch 100 Fr. - ohne Lebensmittel.
Dann brach mein Kartenhaus zusammen.
Dadurch rutschte ich
auch in eine Depression,
weil ich keinen Ausweg mehr wusste.
Ein Klinikaufenthalt
war unausweichlich.
Erst auf Drängen ihrer Therapeutin
hat sie
bei der Schuldenberatung angerufen.
Die Zugehörigkeit zu einem Fasnachts-
verein hat ihr sehr geholfen.
Jedes Jahr näht sie ihr Kostüm
möglichst günstig um.
Der Fuchs stammt vom Vater
eines Kollegen, der Jäger ist,
der genug davon zu Hause hat.
Dieser Fuchs musste
nicht für mein Kostüm sterben.
Das ist von einem alten Kostüm,
da änderte ich den Ärmel ab.
Aber auch im Verein hat sie
belastende Erfahrungen gemacht.
Schulden haben ist ein Tabu,
redet man darüber,
kommt es meist nicht gut an.
Wenn der Verein
ein Fest organisierte,
stand ich jeweils hinter der Bar -
und hatte mit Geld zu tun.
Sofort wurden Stimmen laut:
"Kann man ihr das anvertrauen,
denn sie hat Schulden?"
Ich offenbarte, dass ich Schulden
habe, deswegen aber kein Dieb sei.
Das sind auch extreme Vorurteile.
Das finde ich echt krass.
Ich wäre dumm, aus der Vereinskasse
100 Fr. zu stehlen.
Dann hätte ich vielleicht 100 Fr. -
aber nachher keine Kollegen mehr.
Diese 100 Fr. sind es nicht wert.
Erika hat immer gearbeitet.
Soziale Kontakte und Anerkennung
aus dem Umfeld - beides ist wichtig,
um aus der Negativspirale
herauszukommen.
Auch Donald hatte immer einen Job.
Aber erst vor drei Jahren hat er den
gefunden, der wirklich zu ihm passt.
Das hat geholfen.
Früher suchte ich den Ausgleich
wirklich in meiner Freizeit.
Arbeit war für mich damals ...
... sprayen und Alkohol.
Diese Arbeit
erfüllt mich jetzt dermassen,
dass ich mit all diesem Zeug
aufgehört habe.
Ich konnte damit wirklich
abschliessen.
Und ja ...
Es ist definitiv eine totale
Veränderung, seit ich hier arbeite.
Seine Firma arbeitet ausschliesslich
mit Naturfarben.
Aus diesem Farbpigment kann man
sehr viele Farbtöne erschaffen -
mit verschiedensten Materialien.
Und genau das
macht mir wirklich viel Spass.
Für die Renovation eines Hauses
muss er den richtigen Farbton
für die Fensterläden finden.
Aber seine Vergangenheit
holt ihn immer wieder ein.
Die 15'000 Fr. Busse
aus seinen Sprayer-Aktivitäten
hat das Gericht nun in einen Vollzug
von drei Monaten umgewandelt,
den Donald nächstens
mit Fussfesseln absitzen muss.
Seine finanzielle Situation und
die Geschichte mit den Fussfesseln
hat er im Geschäft
aber immer sofort kommuniziert.
Schon bevor ich hier
zu arbeiten begann, merkte ich,
dass es am einfachsten ist,
wenn ich offen damit umgehe,
und nicht erst herumdruckse
und mache
und irgendwann
in einem Jahr damit herausrücke,
ein Geständnis ablege:
"Du, ich habe Schulden."
So verkrampft man sich
bloss in sich selber,
und dann wird es immer schwieriger,
damit herauszurücken.
Guten Tag.
- Hoi.
Ja, was haben wir denn Gutes?
Ich wäre eigentlich sehr froh,
wenn du mir diese EWZ-Offerte
überprüfen könntest.
Gut, mache ich doch.
- Gern.
Donalds Chef geht sehr entspannt
mit seiner Schuldensituation um.
Für mich ist das
eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich betrachte Donald ...
... als einen Mitarbeiter,
als einen Kollegen,
als jemanden, der sehr wertvoll ist.
Mich als Arbeitgeber
interessieren seine Fähigkeiten,
was und wohin er will,
wie er sich entwickelt.
Seine Schulden -
das ist seine private Geschichte.
Das geht mich nichts an.
Auch dass Donald bald mit Fussfesseln
zur Arbeit kommen wird,
stört ihn nicht.
Das ist für mich kein Thema.
Er wird hier seine Leistung machen
und der Donald bleiben, wie er ist.
Ob er eine Fussfessel trägt
oder nicht,
interessiert mich
eigentlich nicht gross.
Viel mehr interessiert er sich
für Donalds Kunst.
Dieser hat eine alte Technik
auf Kalkplatten
mit seinem Sprayer-Know-how
kombiniert.
Sein Chef fände es spannend, wenn man
diese Platten verkaufen könnte.
Und vielleicht wär's gar
eine neue Einnahmequelle,
die Donald helfen könnte,
aus den Schulden herauszukommen.
Viele Leute rieten mir: "Das musst
du im Internet irgendwie verkaufen!"
Aber für mich stimmte das nie.
Ich habe diese Platten
an diejenigen Leute verschenkt,
die ich mag und mir etwas bedeuten.
Irgendwann kam mir die Idee,
das über das Geschäft
als Auftrag abzuwickeln,
dann wäre das
eine ganz andere Ebene,
um damit etwas Geld
verdienen zu können,
dann können
auch andere Leute davon profitieren.
Wie schwierig es ist,
wenn keine Stabilität im Job da ist,
zeigt die Situation von Kiri.
Die 24-Jährige jobbt Teilzeit
und ist in eine WG gezogen,
weil sie ihre Wohnung
nicht mehr bezahlen konnte.
Sie steht vor einem ziemlichen
Scherbenhaufen und muss schauen,
dass möglichst bald
mehr Geld reinkommt.
Jetzt habe ich mich gerade
um einen Wunschjob beworben.
aber der Haken daran ist
mein Betreibungsauszug,
weswegen ich diesen Job
vielleicht nicht bekomme.
Jetzt hoffe ich darauf, dass mir
der Chef trotzdem die Chance gibt,
damit ich meine Schulden
irgendwann auch abbezahlen kann.
Kiri ist zum wiederholten Mal
in einer Lohnpfändung
und lebt darum
auf dem Existenzminimum.
Je nachdem, wie viel
ich in einem Monat arbeite,
erhalte ich den Lohn.
Alles, was über
meinem Existenzminimum liegt,
muss ich dem Betreibungsamt abgeben.
Wie viel ist das konkret?
Mein Existenzminimum
beträgt rund 2'700 Fr.
Alles,
was Kiri darüber hinaus verdient -
im Moment sind das
400-500 Fr. im Monat -
behält das Betreibungsamt
zur Schuldensanierung.
Und was rechnest du,
wie lange das dauert?
Das dauert relativ lange.
Weil meine Steuern nicht ins
Existenzminimum eingerechnet werden,
wenn ich das jetzt
alles richtig verstanden habe,
werde ich meine Steuern
nicht bezahlen können.
D.h., dass auch diese
weiterhin betrieben werden,
und dass es irgendwann
zu einer Pfändung kommen wird.
Das ist ein Rattenschwanz,
der immer weiter geht.
Aber ich hoffe, dass ich irgendwann
einen besser bezahlten Job bekomme.
So könnte ich etwas schneller
aus dem Ganzen kommen.
Ob sie das geschafft hat und wie es
ihr in der Zwischenzeit geht,
wissen wir nicht.
Kiri war nach diesem Dreh
nicht mehr erreichbar
und hat auf diverse Mails und SMS
auch nicht reagiert.
Donald hat regelmässig Termine
bei der Schuldenberatung.
Sie haben
alle Quittungen aufbewahrt?
Ja.
- Können Sie mir diese bitte zeigen?
Er verdient etwa 4'800 Fr. im Monat.
Jetzt geht es erstmal
ums Grundlegende.
Sehr gut.
Darf ich mal schauen?
- Ja, klar.
Die von April
haben wir schon gemacht.- Ja.
Aufgrund dessen haben wir ...
... das Budget erstellt.
Gut.
Das sind hauptsächlich Lebensmittel.
- Das meiste, ja, genau.
Aus Sicht der Schuldenberatung
oder einer Budgetberatung
ist es wichtig,
dass Sie jetzt lernen,
wie Sie mit dem Geld umgehen.
Gerade bei Lebensmitteln
ist es wichtig,
dass Sie das Geld richtig einteilen.
In Ihrem Fall sind das
ungefähr 240 Fr.- Ja.
240 Fr. müssten Sie jeweils montags
auf der Bank abheben
und in ein Couvert legen.
Ja.
Ihre Freundin und Sie
können daraus Geld nehmen,
es muss einfach bis Sonntagabend
für Lebensmittel reichen.
Jawohl.
Wenn es leer ist, haben Sie
das Budget überschritten.- Ja.
Dann gibt es nichts mehr, oder Sie
leben von Resten oder Spaghetti.
Mit Bargeld bekommen Sie
einfach ein besseres Gefühl dafür,
was das Leben kostet.
420 Fr. zahlt Donald jeden Monat
zusätzlich an die Schuldenberatung.
Katharina Blessing versucht damit,
über drei Jahre die Schulden
reduziert zurückzukaufen,
d,h. mit Einwilligung
der Gläubiger.
Das ist die einzige Chance,
wie es überhaupt gelingen könnte.
Wenn beide ihre ganzen Schulden auf
diese Weise abzahlen würden mit dem,
was ihnen jetzt zur Verfügung steht,
würde es weit über 20 Jahre dauern.
Das ist nicht planbar,
das ist nicht zumutbar.
Und sie würden sicher aufgeben.
Eine andere Möglichkeit für Donald
aus seiner Misere rauszukommen,
wäre ein
Restschuldbefreiungsverfahren:
man ist nicht mehr auf das Einver-
ständnis der Gläubiger angewiesen.
Ein solches wird im Moment
auf politischer Ebene diskutiert.
Yves De Mestral macht sich
seit Längerem dafür stark.
An einer Tagung des Dachverbandes der
Schweizer Schuldenberatungsstellen -
zur Vernehmlassung
des neuen Gesetzes -
ist er als Referent eingeladen.
Es werden verschiedene Varianten
eines Schuldenschnittes diskutiert.
Wer sich eine gewisse Zeit,
drei bis fünf Jahre, wohl verhalten
und keine neuen Schulden
gemacht hat,
dem darf allenfalls
ein Schuldenschnitt gewährt werden -
wie das im Ausland
eigentlich fast überall möglich ist.
Nur zwei Länder in Europa
kennen dieses
Restschuldbefreiungsverfahren nicht.
Österreich
hat auch ein mehrstufiges Verfahren.
Und auch Deutschland
geht ebenfalls davon aus,
dass die Verschuldeten
eine zweite Chance verdient haben.
In Schuldenberatungskreisen
ist man sich einig,
dass ein Restschuldbefreiungs-
verfahren für die Betroffenen,
für die Gesellschaft und
für die Wirtschaft Vorteile hätte,
weil Überschuldete so wieder am
Wirtschaftsleben teilnehmen könnten.
Kredite
sind gesellschaftlich gewollt.
Man gibt den Menschen Geld,
damit sie konsumieren,
damit sie die Wirtschaft ankurbeln.
Das Pendant für die
kleine Minderheit, die scheitert,
die ihre Kredite
nicht abzahlen kann -
dafür zahlen alle anderen Zins, das
ist im Kredit schon eingepreist -
ist die Möglichkeit
der Entschuldung,
das eigentliche Pendant zu einer
gewollten Konsumkreditfinanzierung.
Man könnte auch dort fordern:
"Ihr müsst viel genauer prüfen,
wem ihr Kredite gewährt."
Aber das würde
den Konsum auch abwürgen,
das will man verhindern.
Andererseits
braucht es die Möglichkeit,
sich entschulden zu können.
In der Schweiz betragen die
Gesamtschulden von Privatpersonen
aus Verlustscheinen mind. 20 Mrd. Fr.
Nur gerade 17 % davon
können zurückbezahlt werden.
Wo praktisch nichts zu holen ist,
wie bei Donald,
würde eine solche Entschuldung
Sinn machen, meint de Mestral.
Weil er sich
in der Situation befindet,
dass er jeden Monat
substanziell etwas abliefern kann,
einen Teil seiner Schulden
abbezahlen kann,
dann wird ihm eine auf max. vier
Jahre befristete Restschuldbefreiung
eine gute Motivation sein,
damit er weiss,
dass er vier Jahre lang
eine harte Zeit durchleben muss,
aber nachher hat er
den Schuldenschnitt geschafft.
Doch, ich denke, gerade bei ihm
wäre das ein idealer Weg,
um aus dieser Situation zu kommen.
In der Zwischenzeit hat Donald
die Fussfesseln bekommen,
um so die Strafe aus seinen
Sprayer-Aktivitäten abzuzahlen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist ...
Am Anfang war das Ganze
extrem unrealistisch.
Es war nicht greifbar.
Jetzt nach knapp dreieinhalb Wochen
muss ich sagen,
habe ich mich
eigentlich daran gewöhnt.
Man muss sich an die Zeiten halten,
die ich mit dem Justizvollzug
vereinbart habe.
V.a. gegen Feierabend hin
ist das nicht leicht einzuhalten.
Das Nachhausekommen
ist immer die schwierigste Zeit
mit dem Verkehr und so,
aber sie sind sehr kulant.
Man kann mit ihnen reden, und wenn
es zu einer Verspätung kommt,
muss man anrufen und Bescheid geben.
Zwei Monate muss er noch.
Dadurch wird
sein Schuldenberg kleiner,
aber es bleiben aber
immer noch rund 73'000 Fr.
Mit Abzahlen
geht es nur harzig vorwärts:
Das Budget ist eigentlich
bei Weitem noch nirgends,
obwohl wir uns
schon mehrmals zusammensetzten,
um das so einzurichten,
aber wir haben gemerkt,
dass mit den laufenden Kosten
und den Ratenzahlungen ...
Andauernd schneit es einen Verlust-
schein rein, den wir zahlen müssen.
Es ist megastreng und hart,
aber eigentlich andauernd
mit Erfolgserlebnissen gespickt.
Wenn man sich dem annimmt
und mit den Leuten redet,
sich an die Abmachungen hält
und regelmässig zahlt,
dann geht es Schlag auf Schlag -
und es wird immer besser.
Vielleicht wird ja aus seinem Projekt
mit den Kalk-Graffitis doch noch was.
Für Donald ist es nur schon
ein Erfolg zu merken,
dass er aktiv etwas tun kann,
um seine Situation zu verbessern.
* Sanfte, gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
Auch für Erika wird es immer besser.
Als sie mit der Schuldensanierung
begonnen hat,
ist sie mit einer Kollegin zusammen
in eine WG gezogen
und konnte so ihre Wohn- und
Haushaltskosten massiv reduzieren.
Wir beschlossen, dass beide anfangs
Monat 200 Fr. in die WG-Kasse legen.
Damit können wir den
monatlichen "Grosseinkauf" bezahlen.
Dabei achten wir
auch sehr auf Aktionen.
Diesen Reibkäse z.B. gab es
in einer Zwei-Für-Eins-Aktion
zu einem reduzierten Preis.
In unserer WG haben wir ein monatli-
ches Budget von 400 Fr. fürs Essen.
Das macht 100 Fr. pro Woche,
die wir nicht immer ausgeben.
Nach Bezahlung
von Krankenkasse, Handy und Strom
bleiben Erika so noch
300 bis 400 Fr. im Monat.
Weil sie nicht mehr auswärts isst,
reicht das gut.
Ich koche eigentlich
immer etwas mehr,
damit es auch
für das Abendessen reicht -
und für das Mittagessen,
das ich zur Arbeit mitnehme.
Ja, das reicht,
denn von gestern hat es
noch etwas Rüeblisalat übrig.
Erika hat sich
von ihrer Depression erholt.
Sie weiss auch: Ihre Durststrecke
wird nicht mehr so lange dauern.
Mein Plan für das Danach ist:
Alles, was ich jetzt
von der Schuldensanierung
auf den Weg mitgegeben
bekommen habe, will ich beibehalten.
Ich werde ein Budget erstellen
und mein Geld nicht mehr
für unnötige Sachen ausgeben.
Das werde ich schaffen,
weil ich nie mehr
in diesen Scheiss geraten will.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Roger Schmid, Andrea Werlen - 2022